le premier moment qui a été très
commentée est repris c'est dès le début
de la soirée lors du propos introductif
lorsque bruce toussaint est revenu sur
les complications d'organisation de
l'émission rappelez-vous l'émission
devait se dérouler à la base à montreuil
on avait reçu d'ailleurs le maire de
montreuil et non pas au vert vie d'amy
reg zemmour n'était pas le bienvenu à
montreuil la mairie n'a pas voulu sa
venue enfin ils nous ont dit qu'ils
n'avaient pas ils pouvaient pas
d'interdire nous alors me voilà on n'est
pas très très chaud pour s'intégrer dans
des manifestations voilà exactement ait
lieu dans lequel l'émission devait se
tenir a rompu le contrat avec bfm tv il
est donc revenu dessus hier soir eric
zemmour a dévoilé qu'il était accompagné
maintenant de six policiers avec lui
regarder
pour tout dire on a eu un mal fou à
faire cette émission dans ce département
pourquoi parce que plusieurs villes
plusieurs lieux ont refusé de vous
accueillir ctk de montreuil par exemple
c'est un lieu qu'on avait choisi très
beau lieu 1 voir leur cité pour faire de
la pub les très beaux lieux et au
dernier moment sous la pression du méat
patrice bessac non il a dit que vous
véhicules y est la haine la violence et
le racisme moi je suis très triste je
vais vous dire sincèrement vous savez
je suis venu avec deux voitures et avait
que six policiers c'est pas mal déjà
voilà donc il a six policiers avec lui
et irrigue les moyens oui ben bernanke
franchement je suis je rejoint alors le
siffle le score est pas très bon ben on
s'exile moyens banon mais ses rivaux on
sait que contre onze et mûri son projet
mûri son beau temps c'est qui va drainer
une grosse audience surprise c'est
triste mais il y avait quand même même
c'est l'effet de surprise à chaque fois
on s'attend à ce qu'il a il révèle des
choses importantes et hier soir je vous
contera vois que tu dit valérie basso
qu'on n'a rien appris par yacine on
assiste à un nouveau il a il a reparlé
du mur devait monter des murs tout en
souplesse payer après c'est vrai que le
statut du débat c'est vrai qu'on se dit
voilà ça il manque quelque chose c'est
pas grand chose très honnêtement hier
soir alors justement parlé du mur voilà
il existerait n'est pas sur les réseaux
sociaux de bfm mais il était très
commenté cet extrait sur le mur regarder
savez qu'il ya un grand débat
actuellement au sein de l'europe pour
savoir si on construit des murs ou à
l'entrée des frontières européennes
il ya beaucoup de pays qui sont
favorables la pologne la grèce etc et la
france et l'allemagne refusent et la
commissaire
européenne chargée de ces questions là
une suédoise madame johansson refusant
10 ans ou la la la la la la la l'europe
ce n'est ne pas être construire des murs
moi je ferait basculer la majorité
européenne en faveur du mur qui sera
financée sur fonds européens parce que
c'est indispensable
et je pense que les pays qui ont fait un
mur comme la hongrie ce sont eux qui
défendent la civilisation européenne
beaucoup mieux que les gens comme une
affaire de choix dans sa grosse nous
voulons faire de muret toutes les
frontières
guillon médiatiquement je trouve qu'il a
réussi son coup on l'a dit ça a mieux
marché que la levée des pancartes un oui
on l'a dit ça a mieux marché que la
première il ya eu des vrais moments de
télé comme celui ci est pure je vous
jure que c'est un beau score pour
l'émission il on ferait sens une 620 me
et labit sens qu'il faut une vraie
progression était pourtant dans ce matin
avec 4 points il ya eu des mre ont
vraiment télé puis sur le fond là on lui
reprochait souvent ne pas avoir de
programme là au moins il a sorti dès la
sortie des mesures concrètes dont les
gens vont se souvenir pour moi
médiatiquement c'est un pari réussi pour
eric zemmour et puis vous vous
intéressez à la politique et vous
regardez les meetings etc mais pour les
gens qui regardent cyril mais qui ont
leur découvert aussi chez bruce
toussaint il a il a dit des choses quand
il se compare quand il dit que
l'immigration il fait comme georges
marchais moi je n'ai pas beaucoup
entendu ça à part ce n'est pas à part
dans son meeting où il le dit mais si tu
suis pas son meeting voilà sur le mur je
trouve que c'est pour la première fois
moi il est vraiment entendu je n'avais
pas entendu ailleurs
pardon mais
le côté très trust de zemmour là ils
l'affirment avec les roms c'est le mur
qu'on va avec la frontière mexicaine lui
c'est carrément des frontières et
d'idées des murs pour protéger la
civilisation européenne
tout d'un coup il a cédé points de son
programme sur lesquels il est revenu
alors qu'avant on avait un peu l'équipe
des choses là on peut débattre avec lui
de ces choses là quoi quand même alors
c'est le moment qui a fait également
beaucoup parlé c'est
cet échange entre eric simon et zina
alors qu' une habitante d'aubervilliers
retraité âgé de 64 ans islam immigration
prénom les changes a été hyper pendu
entre les deux regardez vos parents
n'ont pas respecté la loi parce que zina
n'était pas dans le calendrier vous
n'auriez pas dû vous appelez zina et que
c'était interdit par la loi je vous le
signale mais ce ne sont pas les prénoms
qui font une personne je suis là pour
sauver la france et le peuple français
de l'islam en cui de l'islam et de son
métier monsieur zemmour avec je dis ce
que je veux vous dites ce que vous
voulez maintenant ça suffit le
hockey oh là là bas vous avez entendu
m'a demandé de me taire mais c est nous
arrêter de motos coupé sans cesse le
dialogue si vous parlez tout le temps
quand aux femmes non non non non je vous
ai écouté longuement et salons la us
devrait en bulles louis donc après
gérard répondre si vous m'interrompez
tout le temps il ya deux amours et
madame usines là monsieur bruce
toussaint tous et merci pour votre
franchise voilà pour ce débat vif
alors raymond d'abord dire que bruce
toussaint c'est celui que je préfère le
plus dans les journalistes parce que
j'adore sur le thon j'adore la personne
comme ça c'est le valideur ses
classiques votre avis compte buchner
mais ça ça veut dire j'ai jamais de bien
sûr les journées sans doute pas raison
âgées c'est vrai qu'on puisse avoir est
en plus un sort permet culotte je dois
je ne connais pas dans la vie mais
j'avais c'est un amour après le
dispositif de ça moi j'aime bien parce
que ça met sa main on voit on voit
vraiment ça ils partent à visage
découvert les hommes politiques ça en
direct moi j'aime pas trop le plateau
parce que je trouve sa terne l'on ne
peut pas par exemple ce continent on ne
peut pas qui fait face à baba et ne pas
et ne pas aimer ça c'est là on met ses
six ont visé candidats devant leurs
actes là le mur on ne savait pas on tout
tout doucement ou le précédent
dispositif est pas tout à fait le même
temps là les candidats se dévoilent il
parle du mur il va raconter d'autres
choses de son programme les gens ont
besoin de savoir pour qui ils vont voter
que ce soit zemmour que ce soit pécresse
que ce soit hidalgo ils ont besoin de
savoir pour qui ils vont voter et plus
il y aura débat mieux ce sera moi je
trouve que il se découvre et moins et
s'est découvert avec zina moi j'adhère
pas du tout il s'est découvert avec le
mur j'adhère pas du tout comment tu fais
ton mur de l'île jusqu'à nice qui c'est
qui
j'étais prêt c'est-à-dire que nous
européens on va se fermer des autres a
fait ça on est meilleurs ce qui ferait
pas une alliance avec anne hidalgo pour
les travaux
[Applaudissements]
quelque chose m'a gêné dans l'émission
c'est justement à propos de ce moment là
qui est un bon moment de télé c'est le
casting mais pourquoi je trouve que le
casting moi j'attendais des gens entre
guillemets des vrais gens qui parlent de
leur vie quotidienne et pour moi le
casting était beaucoup trop politiser
ces dames qui n'a pour moi elle aurait
dû dire je suis une militante d'extrême
gauche très bien vous avez le droit adam
elle aurait dû le dire c'est ce qu'on
reprochait des gentils alors elle était
dans le meilleur il ya plein de gens qui
ont dit le casting normalement vous
n'avez vous voulez parler de gens qui ne
sont pas politisés la société civile
avec zina ou pas alors in a pour finir
juste qu'elle dise qu'elle est d'extrême
gauche qu'elle dise aussi qu'elle
soutient la cause palestinienne qu'on a
le droit mais qu'elle le dise j'ai
trouvé qu'ils avaient beaucoup
d'hypocrisie le dise quoi presse qu'elle
était obligée de le dire bah oui mais ça
oriente si c'est de la transparence
elle demande de la trois mois et moi je
suis moi je suis je suis d'accord sur un
truc c'est vrai que justement quel
disque ali elle est politisé sais pas
j'ai donc mais ça non plus capable de
donner son avis aussi bien entendu mais
ça oriente quand même en toute
transparence le téléspectateur vers la
réalité de ce que pensent les gens là je
trouvais que on essayait un peu de noyer
le poisson en nous présentant des vrais
gens qui sont des gens impliqués
politiquement c'est ce qui m'a gêné
guillaume je pense que ça d'accord je
pense qu'ils ont aussi muscler le
casting parce qu'on est face à ces sur
et débattre face à zemmour c'est très
difficile façades en face à va il était
face à des gens qui sont habitués des
plateaux télé donc les rails au niveau
et il ya des gens qui peut avoir des
idées qui sont très légitimes une percée
brochier
c'est normal c'est comme quand on aime
quand jean marc candidats effet sur ces
news c'est normal qu'ils cassent un
minimum les gens parce que voilà
sissina je suis désolé moi c'est un vrai
moment
c'est incroyable moi c'est ce que je
veux voir franchement voilà j'ai trouvé
ça j'ai trop moche mais comment draguer
qui va rester dans cette campagne les
changes avec zina il était très fort il
faut chaque fois que dans les moeurs
politiques on parle de casting alors
qu'on est là pour parler des français
bonjour ça choquant forcément fait un
casting non je vais les donner on est
face à des français on apprend des gens
des gens qui n'en prendrait contraire
oui mais alors oui bel air donc là alors
c'est pas ça tu découvres découvre une
émission de télé tomber et on sait pas
d'être la world class et un débat
politique ce n'est pas une somme tenue
comme les autres je les doigts puisque
puisqu'on va dans ce dispositif là tu
vous allez on va parler sur des
thématiques précises on prend des
français qui y portent cette thématique
là et alors après la seule chose
effectivement c'est qu'on aurait pu dire
des transparences anciennes je travaille
dans une
association
alors alors alors assassinat on apprend
que zemmour en fait il s'en fout on est
soit avec lui sa voix contre lui et en
fait il veut pas de rassemblement c'est
quand même un truc hyper important il
est moi la démocratie c'est ça si on est
contre moi je m'en fous moi je veux
qu'on me suivant fait dany oui surtout
que pendant toute l'émission en fait je
trouvais ça bien c'est que chaque
intervenant ont demandé pour qui l on
leur disait pour qu'ils avaient
la mission in a refusé de le dire c'est
la seule autre
transparence il aurait pu quand même 2
voilà c'est important de savoir d'où on
parle alors il ya 2 84e merci le 4e au
mans qui nous a marqués c'est cet autre
échange très franc avec un jeune homme
d'une trentaine d'années alwyn qui va
demander quelle était sa légitimité pour
devenir président en étant condamné à
neuf reprises regardez ça vous
sentez-vous légitime à devenir président
de la république sachant que vous n'avez
pas un casier judiciaire vierge
c'est une très bonne question pour finir
et je vais aller très vite
j'ai été condamné
deux fois vous avez raison la deuxième
fois je suis pendant six commis 10
devant la cour européenne mais peu
importe et la première parce que j'ai
refusé de faire appel parce que
justement je considérais que la justice
n'avait rien à faire dans une bataille
idéologique et politique j'ai été
condamné pour délit d'opinion
délits d'opinion je n'ai volé personne
je n'ai tué personne
je ne suis pas un délinquant
alors
c'est pas une opinion qu'il avait
exprimée c'est un délit c'est pour ça
que
j'ai trouvé l'émission franchement je
les ai fait moi je me dis voilà c'est
pas pareil je suis trouvé qu'ils ont
fait une bonne initiative et une belle
émission même avec valérie pécresse
avait bien deux mais l'émission c'est
une question à deux balles ça parce que
moi je pense que celui qui est condamné
ne doit pas pouvoir se présenter et on a
plein de mecs qui sont députés qui se
présenteront été condamnés par la
justice ils sont quand même député et ça
c'est une question de laura lice oui
c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de professions
pour lesquelles on demande un casier
judiciaire donc et ce serait
parfaitement logique qu'on le demande
aussi moi ya quand même une chose aussi
on a beaucoup parlé du casting mais on
n'a pas parlé du lieu moi ce qui me
dérange aussi c'est le lieu c'est à dire
qu'on hors des plateaux télé eric
zemmour est pas où il va dans le 93 donc
nécessairement ça oriente aussi le débat
il sait savoir qu' il est il a besoin
d'être escortés par des policiers qui
l'avaient être escorté par la sécurité
ont fait savoir que ça a été très
compliqué de le faire et ensuite même si
il parle de choses nouvelles comme le
mur etc au final on en revient au même
thématique à chaque fois assez normal il
a fait il a fait plein de vie quant à
eric zemmour mais limite son retrait à
tort c'est que j'ai 26 jours cela
constaté c'est vrai que et c'est pour ça
claque bris question qu'on peut se poser
soit s'est il fait face à baba sy alors
je le dis on a fait un million neuf cent
mille avec jean luc mélenchon 2 millions
300 mille avec eric zemmour mais aussi
pourquoi je vous dis il y avait une pub
entre tpm pays et le fassent abattre
dans luc mélenchon signalé paul put
d'entre eux face à bah jean luc
mélenchon si ç'avait été pareil on
aurait fait 2 millions 3 je pense qu'on
aurait fait voilà on aurait fait
exactement le même score parce que
forcément on démarre d'un peu plus bas
parce qu'on on démarre après la pub en
revanche sur les les moins de 50 ans on
a fait plus sur l'émission avec jean luc
mélenchon que sur l'émission avec eric
zemmour mais c'est vrai que partout où
il passe il fait des records d'audience
travail alors est ce qu'il ya une
corrélation entre le vote et les
audiences c'est la question qu'il faut
se poser puisque valérie pécresse elle a
fait 6 120 me et en plus c'est avec
bourdin alors je bruce toussaint il est
extraordinaire mais c'est vrai que
melbourne je pense qu'il est plus connue
post ou cinq ans en plus il ya eu toute
la polémique etc elle a fait 600 amis et
hier eric zemmour fait 900 mille
téléspectateurs est-ce qu'il ya pensé
laurent une corrélation entre le vote et
les audiences à t'annoncer rien à ce que
j'ai trouvé à zemmour
monomaniaque comme d'habitude c'est
globalement 2 on peut lui poser
n'importe quelle question tour revient à
l'immigration deuxièmement il ne donne
jamais aucun chiffre sasson son truc
surréaliste de créer un mur je
privilégie un mur autour de l'europe
faut savoir que trump on le dit jamais
il a voulu faire le mur encore le
mexique et a en fait arrêter au milieu
arrêté en plein milieu ça coûtait 10 7
milliards de dollars tout ça je sais
rien au niveau de ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est surréaliste donc que les
gens puissent accepter longtemps va
conduire à la présidentielle à 59 jours
de prendre le pouvoir dire ma solution
c'est de faire un énorme mur mais qui va
contre le mur qui revient à roger j'ai
un projet également joué dit moi je
compte faire un mur entre
c'est symbolique ce mur évidemment pour
lui c'est une façon dit on va faire un
mur entre nous les français et les
autres nous les européens réseau alors
le dernier moment fort de la soirée
reste cet échange très tendu entre eric
zemmour est un prof d'histoire tous les
deux étaient pas du tout d'accord est
vrai qu'eric zemmour il a il adore
l'histoire hfc il
oui je voulais répondre vous voulez
répondre maintenant quand vous voulez
moi et bien dans une semaine
[Rires]
en tant que président de l'association
des professeurs d'histoire-géographie
qui ont été particulièrement choqués oui
par les contre vérités que vous avez
proféré sur le régime de vichy du
maréchal je précise que la paix âgée a
été l'association de marc bloch victimes
de la gestapo avec la complicité du
régime qui soit disant aurait protégé
les juifs français et puis par ailleurs
deuxième nom et vous pouvez lever les
yeux au ciel un c'est comme ça c'est la
d-league est par ailleurs par ailleurs
la milice par ailleurs monsieur les des
manières ce qu'est l'art ailleurs
monsieur zemmour j'ai deux questions à
vous poser si vous permettez un tout en
entrée en vous disant l'épreuve que
c'est pour moi d'entendre toutes vos
généralisation une navrante et vos
amalgames
j'étais en train de ranger mon bureau
importante de rangement de son
conseiller en com a exhorté bon je lui
apprendre à écouter un peu les gens
parce qu'il a un truc est très fort
c'est qu'on fait quand il parle il
envoie des punchline effort est à la
fois content il écoute tu as
l'impression que tu le soul ou deux il
n'arrête pas les mythiques salles
intéresseront
les chiffres et moi jouer une petite
question pourquoi eric zemmour fait
toujours des records d'audience dans les
émissions qu'est-ce qu'il commence à se
faire après ben c'est oui c'est quoi
c'est georges marchais sainte règle
parce qu'avant avant c'était jean luc
mélenchon la dernière campagne c'est
vraiment là c'est vrai que
c'est une vraie star pour moi qu'on les
aime ou pas dans les idées non mais il a
qu'il a quelque chose de stars et je
stark non mais c'est moi je me pose la
question j'adore bruce toussaint mais ce
que face à zemmour il faut pas une star
parce que il a quelque chose de pas
l'ange
à l'éthique jean jacques bourdin session
c'est une star ça ne suffit pas pour moi
alors mais pour eux ils ont peut-être
fogiel mais alors la seule star mais
gérard de bmc ses marques connues comme
ils l'ont fait pendant ces deux mois
et est brûlé deux bruits way faudra
c'est sur mais bon mais bon y'a un
journaliste est une célébrité pour moi
face à zemmour il faut quelqu'un de plus
célèbre de plus connu c'est mon opinion
moi je vais trouver bruce extradé bien
sûr oui même en fait les journalistes
sont très bons les contradicteurs sont
très bon enfin c'était qui s'était
jérémy trottant et philippe cormier est
excellent les citoyens étaient très bien
mais moi j'ai trouvé que c'était un peu
faible malgré tout en citoyens moi je me
souviens pas rendre quand vous aviez
mélenchon vous aviez cette animatrice
infirmière qui était incroyable et je
les trouve comme en garde les gens la
société civile j'ai trouvé parfois un
peu en dessous malgré tout jouer ça
manquait un peu des tofs un peu de
panache un peu de voile à 2 face à
zemmour ans